hey guys welcome back to some foreigner
videos and today is going to be
continuing the mini series of where we
cover every single character in for
honor and I explain to you what they do
what to look out for and how to defeat
these said characters now like if you've
seen these videos before you would know
that I don't do them by faction I do
them by classes first video I did the
assassins the latest video I did the
hybrids the next one which is this one
would be the heavies and the next video
is going to be the Vanguard's so I hope
you all will stick with me for this in
the vanguard class now let's get
straight into it so the first heavy in
the list is the night's heavy known as
conquer conquer has some pretty light
attacks but can be parried if you're
quick enough but they're reasonably
dodge able it's not that bad the shield
block stops almost every combo so the
one thing you have to know is that if
you're playing Kensi you can do the
combo even if they're not hit if they
block it it's completely fine you can
still continue to do your combo cause
still charges up but the shield's known
as valkyrie warlord and conquer are the
only ones apparently that can stop this
so you have to hit all three for this to
count so I don't understand I mean I
kind of it kind of makes sense because
if you're guarding with a sword it's not
as stay sturdy or stable if you're
guarding with a shield so just do be
aware they can ruin like your combo to
where you'd have to hit them all the
time for it to work
usually players will start to mix up the
heavy shield heavy shield heavy shield
bash combo where basically they do a
huge swing do a little loop do a little
spin around and then bash you with your
shield into a wall or onto the ground do
it again and then repeat it that's it's
very annoying and it can take off a very
big chunk of your health but the easiest
way to do it is if you can't if you're
like trying to just Rick we could rico
operate when they throw this combo block
the heavy or if you [ __ ] up the heavy
just press a and dodge out of the way of
the shield kind of run away a bit and
come back you know kind of like like
recuperate and then you can go on and
fight him like normal and
you should be just fine one thing you
need to definitely know is that you
definitely need to stay away from walls
and ledges please guys if he shield
bashes you into a wall you're cornered
if he shield bashes you into an awful
ledge you're dead so just be aware of
your surroundings when you fight these
characters all three of these characters
the next character we're going to be
talking about is the Vikings heavy is
warlord warlord has some pretty quick
light attacks with his very small small
and light sword see it doesn't have a
lot of range so you can have the range
of game on him if you're playing one of
the hybrid characters such as Valkyrie
or even law bringer and Nobu she would
work as well some characters like Ken
say can work because of his long I think
it's called an Adachi
I believe I don't remember the exact
pronunciation of his sword it's not a
katana though but most warlord
characters will use the zone attack that
he has which basically he crosses his
arms of the shield and the sword and he
swings in like a X motion like a
crossing motion it comes from the right
the right guards dance always it never
comes from the left and never go up it
would always come from your right so do
be aware of that if he does that weird
cross motion he also can stop combos
using his shield block like I said all
the show characters can do this
he also has a combo that will contain a
head but what he'll do is you you dash
forward press RT he jumps in the air and
slashes down and even if he misses he
can tap the exponent afterwards the
headbutt you and then get a little quick
stab in there now you can parry the
right trigger attack when he jumps in
the air it is variable and it's dodge
able and blockable obviously it's not
unlockable the headbutt is unblockable
so if you miss the dodge or you missed
the heavy attack from the jump that he
does you can dodge out of the way and
then you'll be completely safe from that
or if you dodge out of the way of the
huge heavy attack he throws be aware
that you will need to dodge again for
the head book because he can throw it
down afterwards so the next character
going to be talking about is the samurai
a heavy Nona shoe go
I've heard a lot of shook okay so this
is going to be very interesting
Hugo gives the head is the heavy
character for the samurai and he also
has the most amount of health in the
game only by like 10 or 20 the next
Alois bringer he has a very slow swing
that it can be easily parried and traced
to where it's coming from
his RB is very slow and then his right
trigger is even slower because he
actually has to back up to get some you
know grip on him stance on the swing and
then he hurls it so it's very easily
dodged able for parried whatever you
feel now he does have a unblockable
heavy where if he holds down the right
trigger and then holds it for a bit and
then he'll swing it's like a normal
heavy attack except this is unblockable
the only difference is that this one
takes longer to swing even longer than
the right trigger normal so you can kind
of tell and you can also hear him charge
it up he always has an audio cue every
time he swings it so it's kind of it's
easily noted easily noticeable when he's
swinging it it might be a bit difficult
to get it at times you know just go into
a duel fight eschew goki for a little
bit then you'll completely understand
he has another ability called demons
embrace where he will run at you and hog
out his arms like he's trying to hug you
grab you put him on your foot he puts
you on your shoulders and then breaks
your back now this does some decent
damage and then could lead into a guard
break and then a right trigger or golf
golf ball swinging baseball bat swing
most of the community would call it but
if he's at super critical health like
couple swings and he's dead if he throws
the demons embrace at you and he grabs
you he will one-shot you regardless of
what health you have and the demons
embrace is super dodgeball all you have
to do is that when he's when he's
rushing toward you find the part to find
that timing it's a pretty big window and
then just - left or - right whatever
spate whatever area you have more room
in and you can easily just avoid it and
get a quick heavy attack in because of
him trying to recover from missing he
also loses health of he misses so that's
even worse for this you'd go key player
now if he can't kill himself by doing
this he will drop himself to 1 HP and
and even a minion can one-shot him so he
can go down to very very low health does
a general overview always use the Dodge
button when you see those abilities and
combos that I listed and never stand
near a Ledge for the love of God please
do this for me and never stand your
alleged role wall with these characters
they will [ __ ] your day up you need to
be very aware of your surroundings when
you fight these heavy characters that's
why they're given the name heavy for a
reason so I hope you all did enjoy this
if you liked the video and please be
sure to leave a like comment any other
thing any other ideas you have for these
characters to help out you know some of
the other players that are still
confused after watching the video and
then if you want to see more of these
type of for honor videos please tell me
in the comments and be sure to subscribe
if you are new guys that really does
help me out and I will see you all later
guys and peace out